if in fact Diane Feinstein uh were to
retire um will you nominate an
African-American woman um to restore the
seat that kamla Harris is no longer in
the United States Senate we have
multiple names in mind and the answer is
yes yeah so back in March of 2021 Nome
admitted he admitted that he would
discriminate based on race where he'
have choose Feinstein's successor and
now with the Senators passing at age 90
will Democrats Plan B Nome keep his
race-based pledge joining me now is
Larry Elder 2024 Republican presidential
candidate former California
gubernatorial candidate um Larry
Democrats would answer charges of
Reverse Racism which are are being
lodged here by claiming there's no such
thing first of all as Reverse Racism and
they would claim that by choosing a
black woman the principle of equity that
they believe in so greatly is being
Advanced Larry so on a Friday night tell
us about this Equity uh pledge and and
promise they
have well laia thank you for having me
as I outlin in my book it's coming out
in November called as goes California
this is a race and gender guy in a race
and gender party remember after Bernie
Sanders won the Nevada caucuses and for
one brief Shining Moment he was the
party's front runner in 2020 and then uh
James kurn the longtime leader in South
Carolina endorsed Joe Biden extracting a
promise that if Joe Biden became
president his first nominee would be
what a black female Joe Biden's running
mate black female and as you pointed out
uh Gavin nuam said in the event that
Diane Feinstein cannot finish her term
he would appoint a black female now if
he renak on his promise he is in deep
deep Voodoo by the way he added a caveat
and that is that he won't appoint
somebody who's a black female who's
currently running that means he excludes
Barbara Lee and Barbara Lee put out a
tweet and she was very angry about it
and said he is condescendingly checking
a box but then adding an interim to it
so she had no problem with the Box she
has had a problem she was not the person
uh who is going to be uh the box that's
being checked and by the way if this
were fantasy fantasy football Laura the
ideal scenario is that Gavin newon would
appoint KLA Harris if KLA Harris would
agree to be appointed and then Gavin
Newsome would hopefully be swapped out
for him VP and if Joe Biden cannot fog
up a mirror it is then going to be Gavin
Newsome that's his fantasy football pick
but the problem with that scenario is
KLA Harris yeah well speaking of Harris
she want to be president well wait a
second but I speaking of Harris I'm so
glad you brought her up because she's
really upset over the attacks of that
that have been growing on the diversity
Equity inclusion stuff Larry and this is
what she
said I look at these attempts to attack
Dei diversity equity and inclusion
they're trying to do the same thing they
did with woke they're trying to turn it
against the people who understand
exactly why it is important to focus on
and be alert and awake to what is
happening I don't know what any of that
means but she kind of does she does like
weird hand gestures and it doesn't
actually amplify or explain what she's
saying Larry but perhaps you can
interpret for
me well the party is confused recall the
candidate named Barack Obama 2004 his
coming out speech was in Boston I was
there there's no blue America there's no
red America there's no Black America
there's no White America there's just
one America the United States of America
and then a few months ago he was
defending the use of identity politics
and says he doesn't understand why it's
under attack this is the race and gender
party except it only applies by the way
on their side when I was running for
governor New York Times big long article
about Larry Elder running for a governor
never mentioned that I was black never
mentioned that I would be the first
black governor and I'm fine with that
but on the same day same newspaper uh
mentioned that Kathy hoko was the first
female governor of New York so when you
have a an r at the end of your name it
doesn't matter that you're the first if
you have a d uh that's the only thing
that really truly matters Larry you just
don't have the right views okay just
change your entire political you know
persuasion and then they'll recognize
you for who you really are Larry thank
you great to see you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else